how's it going resumes uh welcome to
ball boy it's described to me as a
horror point and click game I have no
idea what is gonna happen but it says
click the star so like it yes we did I
think it ever go it looks pretty and
there's like this hand there this is
among the sleep it's this what happened
I like his three little fingers I he's
like you don't [ __ ] with me this is my
face that's what I do with any to any
day any day Sun net nice people
I just a slider alright well alright
there we go let's see what this game is
a ball bad I'm really curious it looks
very cool cool art style i oh no it's a
a UFO apparently and okay then god I
hate when oh [ __ ] so [ __ ] loud
Jesus Christ
I be lying if I said I know what was
going on here
but I think a giant sink just molested
that man and he is like a giant snake
just Melissa that man and I need to do
something about it like I'm a landmine
is that it cool
hello that friend oh no I can't right
yeah what about [ __ ] now I can't reach
what about sake flurry all right yeah I
might have ideas I I would see come on
just just try it so hard all right we're
gonna have to find an item to collect
you what about this prom excelencia put
it in my anus now let's let's uh grab it
with the prom we use the prom on them
I don't know why we need that disgusting
at Rocha t maybe we're just like hey we
need to clean this place up
this place does not look good all right
now we have a closet uh-huh that's how
you check in closets excellent thank you
for doing that
we can't reach that either huh
what about this drawler what exciting
things light an arm at an old earwax
thing some candy Oh an apple some
matches and as Statten it says he wants
the candy but he needs to get there got
it
what about now can you go now now the
sauce is in the way what else should be
clear an hour isn't it go my friend go
Gandalf eat that conda [ __ ] I am stop
odd well I don't see anything else I
could click on come on go sir go and
make me proud I love you we could be
friends he doesn't care about that oh
god what happened why am i collecting
all these disgusting things huh all
right well we need mr. buggy so let's
before we preside maybe this electricity
can have something
oh let's zap him okay let's wait for the
right moment to Zappa BAM
how is that not good enough I know
physics and math and [ __ ] alright maybe
he gets attracted to the light I know
that's how mosquitoes work right what
about you buzz no I meant like what
about you t you get attracted come on
thank you that was don't do that in RL
because it won't do you good
alright I think we have the three bags
and I think we're ready Pro Prasad oh my
god poor lemon boy why is he scared of
that yeah but I have the mold sir good
sir I do I'm sorry I'm I'm sorry
it's so cute this is pretty cool game
all right yep I have them what am I
supposed to do to show him all right you
know what here here take this guy it's
been between my balls hope you enjoy it
oh he loves it extra flavor you go have
mr. Webb what else do you want
don't tell me you want mr. bug to mr.
fly I mean he did what a greedy little
[ __ ] there we go
cool oh yeah awesome all right let's go
sassy is checked oh my god that's a mate
oh god what the [ __ ] what was that
um okay then
there was mr. bunny all along I should
have known he's been acting strange
lately that son of a [ __ ] if you like
butts please support them know if you
like boom please support him on
Kickstarter we are not sponsored by any
lightning company well thank you for
clearing that out thank you kindly
that's pretty short as a little too
short wasn't it if you like bold boy
alright so I'll leave a link to the
Kickstarter if you are interested in
this game I think I definitely am I love
point and click games and because they
have so much charm and this definitely
reeks of it and the fact that it's a
horror themed makes me love it even more
and it's pretty cool so I'll link to it
in description go ahead and leave a like
if you enjoy watching and if you want me
to check out the full version was it
comes out if it comes out and I'll see
you in the next one sails and breasts